[Music]
he sexually harassed another sitting
congresswoman it's better than that this
is the first and honestly better than
that this one this is the no I wish this
is the uh first
uh day uh procession of Congress back
since their break
um because they get like more breaks
than School teachers
uh it's insane they no they get they
basically have a
reverse they have a reverse [ __ ] uh
teacher schedule teachers get off like
three four months a year and then like
Congress just works three or four months
yeah so
uh he went back to the scene of the
crime to greet the greet the coming back
uh Representatives
and he recreated this one oh God I did
see this okay yeah well this there's
more than there's there's more but this
is one you want to see one Let's watch
One
Dan I'm with the one the only I've run
into the man the one the only Dan
Crenshaw eye patch McCain but Dan why
are you retweeting Dave Portner saying
he wants me to fail
he called them my match pecanoist
[ __ ] well he did that the last time I
know but it's every time the last time
it was like a really busy crazy yelling
madhouse this is better because it's
just like an intimate you can hear birds
chirping that's a nice beautiful day
everybody's walking outside and it's
just an intimate moment of like hey eye
patch McCain what up homie the other
great the other great thing is here is
like again like everything Dan Crenshaw
talks all this [ __ ] on Twitter but when
he's confronted in real life he doesn't
say anything because he's a [ __ ] and
then he goes as soon as he as soon as he
got back to where he was going he hopped
on Twitter to talk [ __ ] on him and again
of course got ratio through the [ __ ]
atmosphere but ask me why'd you retweet
all that he's got a great point it's
such a basic question why did you
retweet saying you wanted me to fail and
like f me and all that what's that about
like come on bud why did you do that
why'd you do that
I'm gonna put in the video but why did
you retweet all that what do you think
you think I know but why don't you like
me we're both from Texas I can help you
out you're just not America first you're
a globalist you're giving more money to
Ukraine assaulted a 65 year old I didn't
touch you're such a liar we have it on
tape see this guy's still lying I bet
because he's out here still lying you're
so full of it dude that's why you're
gonna lose dude
oh we need people Alex has been dude the
the right was getting stale and it was a
lot of owning libtards with microphones
and being like oh wow you don't know who
Abraham Lincoln was and you can make you
can make a bunch of those channels you
can make Ben Shapiro owning owning
[ __ ] owning [ __ ] middle schoolers
with facts and logic but Alex is going
to the belly of the Beast and going like
why do you give money to them though you
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you on the world
economic Forum eye patch McCain oh Jesus
dude
you're right though like you know people
have been like you know kissing their
asses about like doing all these Town
Hall things yeah like yeah that's kind
of cool and based but like going to the
the actual power broker isn't getting in
their faces what up homie cause he's
just begging for trouble
you know what you know what I'm noticing
Dan crenshaw's like our height merch
because I know how how tall we are
compared to Alex Alex is a tall guy he's
not he tries to be the sativity you're
just a normal guy bro with one eye stop
[ __ ] pretending you're better
actually your words because other
soldiers have two eyes yeah it's true
yeah
I like guys that didn't lose their eyes
yeah listen bad periph McCain [ __ ]
Trump never pulled that one out uh I I
like guys she didn't get their eyes
blown out yeah you think the other eye
is like the eye from the bad guy in Last
Action Hero where he changes it out
every time like you think it's a
bullseye now or a smiley face bro can we
please just
can we please just take a moment to
appreciate the fact that Trump was
elected president
after after
saying about a a congressman and a war
veteran I like guys who didn't get
caught but it just shows you how close
it shows you how much nobody likes
McCain he just literally yeah he's still
got elected president that would have
eliminated almost any other human being
from the job
adding cup of women fat just Rosie
O'Donnell if you ever wonder why they're
still trying to destroy trumps and his
children's lives it's because he went up
against all those people and said things
like like he's there's almost like Stein
almost is like taking from the Trump
Playbook of like I'm gonna go right to
your face and say things that nobody
would have the boss to say to your face
and that guy she didn't get cut
he doesn't like Alex
is one of those people that does insane
persons doesn't have this filter and I'm
not talking about
he's suppressing it but he's somebody
that doesn't
he's going to do something he's going to
do it he doesn't [ __ ] care what you
think
no I know you don't know you don't think
that it's gonna happen guys this guy's a
traitor are you an adult you're a
globalist yeah I'm an adult calling you
out this you lost your eye for weapons
of mass destruction
[Music]
it feels
it feels good
yeah
you left your eye over a lie and he's
pointing it out
and then you're and then like it's like
you got your eye blown out over a lie
and now you're perpetuating that lie and
you're blowing out other people's eyes
people's eyes get blown out it's but
this guy this the Bible said eye for an
eye and Crenshaw took that [ __ ]
seriously
oh [ __ ] maybe crenshaw's like in a
secret group you know like in Assassin's
Creed they used to have to cut their
ring finger off or the blade to come out
in the game maybe to join Karen Charles
group they have to pop your eyeball out
I I do have to I don't remember that
being correct almond I do have to
correct Stein though he didn't get his
eye blown out over weapons of mass
destruction because he was actually in
Afghanistan but
close enough
close enough
it didn't exist and you don't even call
it out weapons of mass destruction that
didn't exist but you know that let me
hear you say something about that
God
she's lunatic why again and you know
what you know why a damn cringe on it
because people go well Dan crutch was a
politician he's not going to yell at
somebody no no no no no no he's not
yelling out next time exactly I was
about to say okay I was about to say oh
girl the reason he's not yelling at Alex
Stein is because he's not a baby yeah I
mean yeah here's the other thing did you
see the hot fresh one that happened
right before we went live
no Eric swalwell oh boy Eric swalwell
Eric swalwell
oh I didn't see this one walking
with his girl just so you know who he's
with
is that Fang Fang no no no no no that's
not that's the difference this is the
one that he said he goes home with oh I
know oh yeah here you go
it's the one that loves him
Eric and there's the picture of feng
finger oh boy
they got it out of like the clearance
rack
of spies are there a lot of good-looking
Chinese women
um no I'm honestly thinking I'm not even
trying to be a dick
man I mean there's a lot out of Filipino
Whip and a lot of hot Vietnamese
whipping women like hot Koreans it was
like one Chinese woman that was like an
actress at one point
yes there's only been one Chinese woman
this was an actress you're right hold on
let me look it up one hot one merch
turns out there's 500 million of them I
meant like I mean and honestly Marsh
this isn't easy because they all look
the same to me Lucy Liu in her prime
Maybe
no but even Lucy Liu I never like out of
the Charlie's Angels Trio I found her
the least attractive yeah
on the count of the Chinese face
um I actually just Googled Chinese
actresses and uh I have to say frozen is
that you Frozen is that you Frozen is
that you Frozen is that you all right
now I have to wait like after the 30
second delayed so we're gonna get we're
gonna get something to show links no no
no no no no no no
oh
the Chinese fire remember when you slept
with that Chinese spy Eric well I never
talked about that same thing cringing
remember you're banging Bang Bang
can I show something else hold on
all these other people
are you guys say no this always happens
every time you know the Congress comes
back and everybody you know you see them
walking up you'll see like different
people protesting on their walk there
but none of them really say anything
Alex on the other hand goes oh a
sidewalk I will also walk with you
let's have a walk let's have a nice
stroll
we give you anal he's gonna you know
he's gonna be the reason they make new
rules uh I have a feeling that he
reaches a Fitbit step goal that day
people are saying that she gave you an
insertion is that true
true
somewhere agree slightly agree some
would agree slightly agree
this is the guy's banging Chinese spies
oh he's going harder he's going harder
Chinese spies
oh it's cringe but it's a good cringe
you know what I mean it makes you feel
good inside it's like it's it's
relieving nobody investigates you Eric
why is that
nobody investigates this guy banging
Chinese spot hey do me a favor Virgie
see if swallow said anything about him
like Crenshaw did on Twitter because
this just happened like a couple hours
ago like it's no big deal
by the way a nice sound effect I like
the pring
oh I'm gonna attack
you know what I did did what I did get
and I just say something no I want to
just say that Alex Stein
um
does not want to kill himself Alex no
Suicidal Thoughts oh